also took out the girl in the front she  was an absolute I'm not gonna say it but  you know what I'm thinking I know we're  trying to talk about the one that was  like over she had this whole freak out  that they just like took out what was it  about you remember we filmed this in  October oh I just remember she was like  very rude like they took out so many  parts of the Liberals just acting insane  like they still looked in the same I  promise you it was 10 times worse my  favorite is the part where you're  talking and they start to like  psychoanalyze you like oh how did you  get this way and then the insults came  why do you hate women you're like I am a  woman and they're like you could have  internalized massage me I'm like oh here  we go that's that's there I start  they're like trying to be your therapist  and I'm like this is why therapy messes  women up today